bei oberding muss in bayern hatten am
dienstagabend kurz nach 22 uhr eine
gruppe erntehelfer mächtig zivilcourage
bewiesen denn sie retteten einem jungen
mann das leben
wir befinden uns hier auf der
ortsverbindungsstraße zwischen
hallbergmoos und oberding wir wurden auf
einen pkw im vollbrand alarmiert mit
einer person noch im fahrzeug
die person wurde dann von ersthelfern
aus dem fahrzeug gerettet das fahrzeug
wurde von uns mit wasser und schaum
abgelöscht und die person ist
mittlerweile auf dem weg ins krankenhaus
schwer verletzt mit verbrennungen
der pkw stand bei unserem eintreffen im
vollbrand ein baumstamm hatte sich auf
der beifahrerseite bis zur rückbank
durch den wagen des 19 jährigen gebohrt
danach geriet das fahrzeug auch noch in
brand die mutigen erntehelfer hatten
nicht eine sekunde gezögert und den
jungen mann aus dem brennenden golf
befreit
bis zum eintreffen der rettungskräfte
kümmerten sich die ersthelfer um den
schwerverletzten während die feuerwehr
das brennende fahrzeug fragen löschte
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren